[Music]
I'm from a border town called San Juan
right next to Mexico thank you
kind of a rough neighborhood our high
school mascot was the cartel so let's
just say we never lost a game
[Laughter]
so weird being from Texas I'm a huge
Dallas Cowboys fan I trust me I know
it's been hard it's almost 20 years
since we won our last Super Bowl AHA ha
ha I realized I feel like I'm in that
relationship that isn't going anywhere
like I have to have a talk with them at
the beginning of the season like ha ha
so what the hell are we doing you
promised me a ring there's no ring here
I'll give you a Super Bowl ring you
don't even get me to the playoffs he
told me we're gonna go I showed up you
weren't there where the hell are you
the Bengals were there where the hell
were you I'm sorry I didn't start seeing
other sports I've been seeing the maps
for about a month now thank you
it's weird you know they've caused me so
much pain that I just find myself on
Sundays getting drunk to forget the pain
you know sometimes I drink so much I
repeat the same question over and over
again
I sound like a drunk Dora the Explorer
you know do you know where my house is
do you know where my house is I need a
map
I drink a lot for obvious reasons I'm
Catholic that's what we do being
Catholic is like having a gym membership
it's like yeah we belong but we never go
it's all right I grew up in a kind of
poor neighborhood the only way you could
tell someone in my family like
neighborhood had money you'd go into
their house and they would have a whole
set of encyclopedias you're like oh ho
ho I knew one was doing good I didn't
know he was doing encyclopedia oh look
he's got the cure they're being poor
having debt that's part of life though
part of being an adult you guys ever
want to find out which one of your
friends doesn't have any debt here's an
easy test wait to the likes there cell
phone rings because people that don't
have any debt they're the only ones that
will answer every phone call without
looking at caller ID first they're not
scared of anyone
hi I'm responsible
brought people on the other hand we
judge that call by calling hey girl how
you doing I'm not gonna get that no the
morgue broke you are the more you laugh
when someone tries to get their money
like hahaha Best Buy
caller ID was the best thing to happen
to poor people when my family got caller
ID my mom stopped answering every phone
call I was so glad I was never kidnapped
cuz that woman would have never picked
up that ransom call it could be the
kidnappers yes but it could be Sears no
no is it weird to say that like my
favorite kidnapping movie of all time is
taken I love that movie so much this
girl gets kidnapped your secret agent
dad comes and saves her it's a fantasy
can you imagine everybody in this room
got kidnapped and you had to rely on
your real dad to come and save you we'd
all be dead I never even met my dad I'd
have to rely on my Mexican immigrant
mother to get that phone call you know
me not stupid I don't know who you are I
don't know what you want if you are
ransom
good luck I got no money what I do have
is a particular set of skills I'm gonna
take the bus to Europe I'm gonna get a
minimum-wage job and I'm going to cook
and clean for you thank you I've been
traveling a lot lately I was recently in
Auckland and a friend of mine sent me
flowers to congratulate me on something
and I didn't know what to do with the
flowers when I left like when I checked
out he's supposed to travel with them do
you throw them away what so I asked my
boyfriend and he was like oh just give
the flowers to the maid I was like oh
okay what if there's more than one maid
he's like Oh would just give each mate a
rose what the hell is this the Mexican
bachelor like what am i doing Maria I
love the way you make the bed it was
comfortable
I slept in it for eight hours you get a
rope other Maria
[Applause]